guys think a lot of my friend Jeff so
thanks guys for hanging so I asked I
mailed Jeff the other that is okay if
you come through to New York I'd love to
do a fireside chat with the company I
want to do more of these with you guys
and I couldn't have thought of a better
guest obviously we got to know each
other quite a bit filming plan of the
apps but I've always known from afar and
we ran into each other a couple
nonprofit events through the years of
how you know impressive of an operator
or an entrepreneur to think or about
marketing medium business just has been
for quite a long time obviously she had
real fame before that world and so I
don't think a lot of people you know
then aren't paying attention realize it
and then I got to really see them
display from business shop standpoint on
the show obviously the show was very
real like we were critiquing businesses
and asking questions and I really
enjoyed him and I'm just extremely fond
of her so one more time please clap it
up for somebody
I think I'm going to ask a couple
questions and then I think we'll open it
up to some questions and then we'll go
on our merry way so first and foremost
just what when did you start thinking
about or or realized that you had
business interests
I think I only approach my career am i
12 laughing I was like what's the long
name like how do I stay relevant and how
do I become a real player and how am I
going to be meaningful and so I was
always pretty strategic and the way that
I approached my career and I thought of
myself as a brand before it was a thing
to think of yourself as a brand I was
always really cognizant that anything
that I associated myself with was going
to be reflective of how people thought
of me yep and and I protected that for a
long time and when I decided to to
launch my own brand I really feel like
all of that thought we got channels and
in the best way I didn't know what when
the outcome would be but I was certainly
very aware of being protective of my
image from day one so on that note next
remember this from a conversation now
let's dig a little bit deeper was there
ever a role that you really jockey for
and we're strategic for or was there
anything that CAA and those characters
were pushing you hard to do that you
passed on based on this thesis yeah
so I never got to really show my chop as
a religion after he was young there was
Gemma food all the good roles a sexy
time and I was like I for whatever
reason I felt like when I was young it
would just be exploited in a way and out
of my control in a way that I wouldn't
be great for my my brand before I really
articulated it that way and I often took
Catholic and Christian I could ever deal
with my guys you know you're like
weirdness and so like that plays into it
but but yeah I did I definitely took
more or passed up on a lot of
opportunities that would have positioned
me as an actress and Hollywood in a
different way maybe in a more serious
way but on the flip side I went the
route of wanting to be global wanting to
Kozelek superhero because of that I
wanted I looked at the marketplace and I
was like what are the things that go
global and it was superheroes
franchises action it was it was pre
horror and it was pre rom-com being
global and so Roscommon to make you like
America's Sweetheart but it really
didn't extend beyond that but you can
get instant payday and you can be the
face of a beauty brand fine or you can
and send that the girl stuff and you can
go into boy land and you can do you know
action hero and I wanted to be an action
hero so I wanted to collect yourself as
an action figure
well yeah of course I have a feel so
yeah I mean I'm good many action asses
over here I started with TV show
indifference name's Cameron called Dark
Angel I was actually offered oh remember
I was 17 and I was if I don't get like a
role by the time in 18 that's going to
really make me feel comfortable when
choosing this as a path as careers and
I'm going to go to school and and it is
degree and have like a real job okay
when you're at that point in your career
you're like okay so between 16 and 18 I
gave myself two years to really kind of
figure out if this was supposed to be my
path in life and I was offered a role in
Fast & Furious and I was also offered
the starring role of James Cameron's
first TV show after he did or his first
project after Titanic and and I took
this James Cameron one and and then from
there I was like alright I guess these
are the stars aligning he's telling me
that I should committee maybe I should
do this for a living
so yeah from there I just thought
strategically about how to maintain that
global awareness and
and I didn't want to be the girl to the
guys that have to concede I wanted to be
the girl that's an absolute beast
and the way to do that was with action
franchises at the time so very cool and
so how do you think about it now like
are you out you're going to act again
like where you where you and you're
looking you're 9 years listen that
really long when you sing bad what does
that mean it's been nine years since one
anybody really care about like that was
okay I know you've done stuff right yeah
but like I got pregnant as I had a kid
at 27 I are pregnant 26 and 27 and I
just working for so long at that point
the workings of those 12 and and hard
core relation 717 so it was a good fall
in 10 years of not having a personal
life yep and not really having any life
outside of working you know why our
weeks often so I didn't sleep much and I
worked a lot and it's a blessing because
it was a dream come true but then when I
actually sat in one place for the first
time and I had like a person like
growing in my stomach and I call my
goodness but she can rely on me to like
stay alive that is true
how is that so then by my perspective
just shifted on like what it means do
you know have the love to be alive and
to have your health and and to want to
operate with a different sense of
purpose yeah mate right over there in
the pink shirt
Nathan excuse me he freaked out when he
found out that the odds of being a human
or 400 trillion to one that happened to
him in LA when we were filming so he
feels that same feeling so so talk about
the early days of the business right you
know it's such a big business now like
all of you should kind of have to take
visitors but you should all visit the
office is amazing what you know it's
just growing up so in such a big way
obviously we've worked with Unilever and
Johnson & Johnson and it gets brought up
all the time and it's so crazy right
because you're really so little and
that's fine but you're like yes but but
they're all scared right and they're all
aware and they're all impressed and I
think look it gets compounded right like
I think that you know it's just so
impressive to watch you build something
so real and so big and compete at the at
a global scale overt and just and what's
interesting as you're going into a
different chapter right you guys were
this digital native brand and now it's
just getting bigger bigger and like and
we yeah and it's happening here right
like they know like I'm like we're not
twenty-five people anymore right and so
like you change and so but you don't
change in spirit you just look
differently at 12 and 17 and 26 and what
have you how are you thinking about the
business like what what's uh what's
exciting what's interesting what give us
a quick little update I think in
my life in general and it's something
that I guess they only really even do
when I got older was I decided at some
point that is as right as I ever thought
I was when I was 18 telling my parents
all the thoughts in the world about how
things should be and I had all the
opinions and said all the things I never
wanted to be the same person ten years
from them and it has a company you know
five years ago we were a very different
company and we've grown up and I hope
five years from now we will be even more
grown up now having wisdom doesn't mean
that you should not have life and spirit
it doesn't mean that you shouldn't be
open and still try and learn and change
and evolve it just means that you have
only the wisdom to not make the same
mistakes more than two or three times
really close fixable but yeah we're an
omni-channel brand of our distribution
knows our model has changed we are more
vertical more expansive as far as like
your our core the beauty thing now right
yeah we're me
in cleaning at the end of the year we
started primarily in mating in personal
care and basic cleaning but we really
like going deep in verticals where we
know we can win and where people have
access to to play and we've really kind
of evolved into a health and wellness
company at the end of the day a company
that pretty human health first no matter
what category and we go into it is
really doesn't matter and education is
as important as the products that we
move and just you know being able to
empower people with the knowledge to
make better choices to me is the
ultimate mission so talk to me about so
this this company started from social
right talk to me about your personal
social media behaviors how do you rolled
you quit like fake account control
people your character so I know
something weird could come out here
really my students work and so do you
have it do use anything not you know I
even told me but I started on Twitter
and evidence first
yep my first account and
in the Facebook and then and Chad yeah
and Pinterest around the time of
Instagram I have to say with whenever
I'm going through a transition in my
life or something new happening like
have a new office or a new house or
doing making over a room like I'm in my
life really yeah it's funny how it's not
like as consistent as like a snapchat or
Instagram but is much more like utility
when you actually use it
we're doing like way too much time you
like pin the [ __ ] out of interest I like
I love it I even know what's wrong in my
brain right now but yeah so I'm like I'm
working most active day-to-day right now
I'm on Instagram and snapchat and and is
your public profile that has millions
and millions of people following the one
that you actually use and so how do you
get through all the noise like creeper
dudes like rowdy
Kaddi yes clearly the block this is the
greatest moment in your property's
history period god it's like you just
kind of just navigate through it yeah I
should actually be a little bit more
strategic for social media but for some
reason I'm not and I don't like no to
post that you know the better time of
the day to corrode is at this time and
you should post this type of content
first I feel like I don't hear this role
I don't follow
I guess a guy you just later donated by
me on fire you know just do a little my
life and that's my life aren't I'm like
into my name chain well you're gonna see
a photo I love it
what so why don't you tell everybody
here a little bit about plan of the app
how did that go how you know was that
fun I thought I was great here they
actually had to brave are my armors up
and match
it's really cool we think that we filmed
in three sets like you pitch then you we
mentor which I get in LA
Big Ups LA and then and then we pitched
the BC but they do an episode where they
follow all the way through so the first
episode of beginning a middle and the
end of the journey of these
entrepreneurs right yes and I think it's
really cool because the first episode is
really featuring on our company's yeah
tell people that right we're in trouble
now so but seriously was it interest
like how to go for you it was like
stressful because no I mean when you're
you're aging on running drunk company
like you just stop thinking about it and
you know how important is to is it is
introversion is your life and um you
know the edge of the matter what just in
the way you're going to figure out how
to like push through and make things
happen and when things don't happen the
way they you want them to happen you're
devastated yeah that was not the fella
like when we didn't pick them that was
bad horrible but but some of them died
her because the company stuck
in their mind they don't know and they
stop well yeah we both American Idol and
the person's like I'm the greatest
singer of all time and it is like rip
art nerds are our body isn't like you
know it hurts them as much as miss her
you know for sure like there's like a
very human scene there and so you don't
want to devastate them to the point of
them not wanting to continue but at the
same time where will something like this
devastate them that much if I may have
no show that successfully and will
wouldn't allow them to be devastated
because every time they they make it
through he ran down hug them and gave
them his cell number and decided to be
best friends with him so let's flip it
are you considering he has much better
what about your media consumption are
what shows are you watching podcast
you're listening it would you like them
so are you consuming any shows Oh Star
Wars yeah actually finds entire yep what
shows am i yes big little life hands man
let's go a telenovela with a lot of
white people yep
all this drama it's like really good
okay
really good what else
[Music]
so I haven't finished the Oh a don't run
a program for the reference isn't like
it gives me anxiety and it's like a
light and I watch of the main event
I'm here my family let's clap it up for
him and we don't win what do you watch
nothing true yeah that's exactly right
you have it
you pretty much Bayless I'm really not
watching anything but but that's because
I am already working cookies yep
[Music]
we had 16 important documentaries is all
the 13 people what the first intro I
mean you saw that documentary way nope
oh I do love documentaries and if I
consume anything to normally that but I
haven't seen it you need man
okay okay comment and it actually really
nice
I'm going to leave right now so you guys
alright what about what about sports
your dad is a hardcore Rams fan which I
respect because they're not good either
did you ever have a was just of them the
holy 16 is here so he's getting mentally
prepared anything with you with
sportsmen at this point and like when
the Lakers are good you're a bandwagon
fan
no I so my husband grew up with Baron
Davis and so up another me with we were
fans of whatever weapon he was on mix
for a few minutes Nick for a little bit
and cover and then Golden State you know
the people who are playing then you feel
more invested like that so whenever I go
to a game and up and stuff like that fun
good I haven't gone to games in a while
good but they're very tall tall and
they're good at all that like it's like
special like you would never be able to
take that off me and never not anything
against you not listen right somewhere
around fourth grade was when I realized
I was more likely to hone the Jets than
to play for them that's the punch honor
I'm not taking it alright let's do some
questions who's got one
oh we ever groaning abusing so we get a
vibration when mentally you like oh yeah
I do I just had my fancy baseball stats
are you here
alright stand up so everybody boost at
he's my main competitor this year in
fantasy baseball but he didn't stress
very well so I'm feeling confident
so he did a collaboration with MLB we
did diapers Assad Salomon Rocker fix my
red father's favorite skin from harden
all
cup next cab mixer basketball sorry not
a funky that's not met introduces
Dodgers Dodgers and the jet giant why
we're perfect oh I love it
yes because you've been affected he's
been affected all right question here
grab this and we have a mic over there
and we can go loud too if we have to
good
say your name so here's this weird name
because I don't find from traditional
you know CG or
Beauty background I don't I never
understood that like the way that people
perceive your brand or the integrity of
your brand or whatever is based off of
distribution and not price point for the
quality of your ingredients
it's literally 1% has to do with
distribution but now the distribution
has always lived on his head with every
CC business and with all of these online
retailers who are like taking people's
lunch and more people who are like give
me an excuse to leave my father is going
to your door I just feel like this is a
transitional time and I'm more than ever
just want to make sure that my products
are in people's hands and that are my
brand is showcased in the best way and
so I don't really have a bias as to
where ancestry
I didn't wanted to have really great
partners and I wanted to be down the
right way Jeff is doing some super rad
she's our like target tuesday target you
need him going into random targets I'm
finding random people and in giving
makeovers on class so everybody next
Tuesday you're allowed to be off to go
random targets under breath I'm so high
today I give to makeovers on teeth to
the membership associate like I was like
nervous because you're like me and
sometimes they might not know who you
are right I mean there's like four of
those people yeah I don't know and any
and they love it all right who else has
got a question
Dante get up here baby that was awesome
Dante that was what you were thinking
yeah you brought it so we're going to
splinter version here and I'm sure you
know we see those you know from kind of
big in blazes individual people and
followers how do you think that
the growth in your business on social
having those 10 people speak am
influences are tricky I actually feel
like the movie the sponsors that had the
like most followers maybe aren't as
trusted as people if you have like 3,000
or in high hundreds because to me it's
like the people who have been authentic
engagement and have that like rabid
family is more the people that are going
to affect change versus someone who's
just so giantesses because we're
pitching products every day is the
thought or or because they're just part
of the machine and most of the people
that are following them are box and we
know that that's what they can be gained
I was never one of those people I never
bought any of my followers and I do
everything myself and there's no agency
or other people that do you know your
judgment my engagement but also it was
like for me to be honest why I'm so
involved in my online persona is because
I felt like my entire career I was in
someone else's hands so whether it was
Fox's hands the Halle Berry but you know
the Machine of the production company
Paragon Sonia whoever and how they
wanted to market me or the publication
that wanted to do the interview of me I
was this version for the GQ reader and I
was at version two Seventeen magazine
reader and I was a person for the People
magazine reader is no part of it was
really me so for the first time I really
to tell my story I got to be real and I
got to have that direct relationship
with myself and and have control over
you know when you my an exact quote the
exact way to the end user and I never
got to do that before and so that's why
I care about it so much and that's why
I've been so evolved and donnelly been
so much of your personal brand into the
company you're like that that's kind of
itself is it frustrating you he was
still dyad like in tonight someone went
home that I had such as gallery access
or would you feel like not it's just
part of your broader story before you
enter just one make sure the other
offices that are watching so question is
around the Basking you know if somebody
went home tonight and said oh I saw
Jessica Alba the actress you put so much
time and effort in building this
business and yourself into it I guess
the question is you would should be you
know frustrated being identified as that
I guess it depends on in the beginning
probably more right I mean people know
me more from one thing first another I
can't expect them to not know me for
that and every tool that I was given the
opportunity to have the career in
entertainment that I that I got to have
actually met back so we're we need to
pursue some people for some of our
videos okay great look
my husband's I was like really
so public do you think that means you'll
probably do it
I you know I don't what do you think
about 71 year old view like hacking
Spain here's the thing when you're when
you're acting like you can always do it
and it's in your you only stop doing and
when you Erlanger and I never want to
play that but it's not like an NBA
player right like you've got that window
you don't have an expiration date how
will you always be get you know get your
little center vein money and when you
skills be the hall engineer for the rest
your life
no but do you get to evolve into
different more meteors different types
of people sure but you could be like a
funny grandma
yeah funny grandma so so I I miss it I
do do I care if people think of me as an
actress it depends on the context if
someone's just trying to be mean
spirited and take away what I've built
then sure it hurts my feelings I am a
sensitive person but if someone just
doesn't really know me from anything
else and I'm like that's really that's
cool
good anybody else yep I probably have
like an unhealthy relationship with a
boyfriend tell me more true where's the
camera yeah I have to say that was far
as like legacy healthy reassessment and
personal fulfillment I never I never
even I never thought that I would be
able to have such a full life and being
an entrepreneur and being able to create
a company and create a vision and create
solutions for people that that'll really
transform our lives and also to watch
people let me throw up in there and
their home life in their own careers and
watch personal development on such an
intimate level because prior to business
I would spend a lot of time with
strangers for about four months and then
I can never see them again at the time
that I spent with them was every day all
day and night and it was the best and it
was the best and he create it was like
some really ancient and relationships
quickly but then they go away
in Sweden there's something so permanent
about going into the office every day
and I see people that I saw five years
ago and they see me so they are today
verse 2 they were when they walked in
five years ago and that so don't just be
how people evolve and to have the
personal touch love them
yep Rebecca come up to the mic oh yes we
got one good oh my god good I don't know
I really forward specifically to Kate
what's most powerful things how many
accidents in your life Wow yeah I know
this is playing a loaded question
because of the pace field wide I mean
100% I've dedicated my life in a weird
way to helping kids and this is the
person I actually kind of thought about
it that way but I was amazed when I was
remember and I wanted please literally
anything would be better than to be sick
and seeing the hospital and to have
surgery and I had multiple surgeries and
multiple health problems and I just I
really just wanted to be anyone else
this is why I wanted to be after like a
wait for that could actually be real as
real as it can be and
superhero and be larger than life
because I was like making overcoming
anything and so yeah I mean from helping
be able to provide families with
products is one thing but even just like
basic essentials you know infant
mortality is a huge issue country and a
lot of babies get suffocated while
they're sleeping because parents can't
provide a safe place for them to sleep
and we did an initiative where we
provided and we still have an ongoing
spinning among the board of this
organization called Vida baby ins and
one of our big initiatives is to give
families a safe place for their for
their beauty sleep so that they never
have to worry about that and that's like
old real thing and and that's incredibly
meaningful I also got the opportunity to
go to Africa with Bono and Kalani around
the world cup to fight for education
reform of global education fund so that
every person had access to a
comprehensive education and most people
who don't have access are women
and so that is incredibly meaningful and
being able to give girls an opportunity
to just empower themselves to give
out of the situation that they don't
want to be in and and change the setting
of life in their own life and so there's
there's been a lot of these
circumstances but yeah I'm very just
thinking about it it's very close I
don't also you get to but probably using
my own little speakers has probably been
the most meaningful but being able to be
part of so much changing and it's scary
and weird and crazy as our country feels
right now with certain political things
I feel like there's enough of us out
there that walk with integrity and care
about the right thing and we're going to
continue to be progressive and how to
operate and then I think the thing that
I learned that has no one told me it's
sort of like being a parent like no one
tells you what you're really in for as
far as the sleepless night and you'll
never not worry again thing that
happened in business you never under
under estimate years ago there's a lot
that you can learn right in school or
through experience and making the piece
but trusting your bed and knowing when
you don't know what you don't know
important is knowing what you do know
and being able to have the humility
support we don't know with experts and
other schools to fill those gaps and
entrusting their best overseas but your
grub it might feel good but they need it
[Music]
I'm really not good enough Nestle 500 of
you is dying today
agencies representation of the mission
goes on free software there wasn't
always that being said it hasn't always
been easy and I think especially the
political climate what I would love to
know is what if I seem have for young
women entrepreneurs that we build this
business successful
you see say specific challenges or
advantages and not affect and then just
know why we have manages I mean that's
just the way it is a health isn't all
doesn't mean to say you know being a
girl you just time configured
talking appearance I never had a
traditional or conventional background
or education nor did I have never system
that got me fair enough I literally had
to pay my own way and I had to figure it
out and and create that happen time
division for myself and it was almost
the naysayers that drove me to improve
my mom and also like when we don't have
anywhere to go but up there's something
this is almost like something mixed
about that because people don't expect
you to fail because they don't think
your people will do anything more than
nothing and so then there's even more
like a fire to prove it makes me camp
and it can make a difference what can
you do I think you have to firstly
figure out what it is you're trying to
do in the world how you how are you
going to be different we look at the
competitive landscape very real
efficient yourself and make sure that
you have a very unique proposition or
perspective or point of view because if
you're just than me to companies why why
do it I think the one thing I would add
just I'll jump into this one because I
love it so much I think the one thing
that true entrepreneurs need to realize
is that the market doesn't care
let me tell you one great thing about
the market like it you know it it wants
to make money right do I think some VCS
may say you don't look the part no sure
but I've got a news alert
I don't usually invest in white affluent
dudes from good families because I don't
think they have a chip on their shoulder
so I'm playing the reverse and the truth
is I've been wrong and I've been right
so I think the one great if you're
purebred entrepreneur you realize you're
getting punched in the [ __ ] Mount
24/7 365 anyway the market is the market
and and if you dwell on what you are and
why you're not winning because of that
you would have never had it's no
different than the people we said no to
please
of circumstance and it's sort of like
blaming your parents it's like yeah
right everyone has a history and you can
blame your parents into blue in the face
but if you only work on like focus on
that you'll never get over it and be an
adult and figure your own life out and
by the way your parents are just trying
to desolated Emmanuel which I learned
but yeah like you just I think if I
would have started to be honest company
when I wanted to start it would have
been charlie and actually having three
years of rejection it gave me the armor
to take on actually getting funding and
starting the company and taking all of
the punches and all any information on
my ads in the year and we know that
constantly can have a and still do a
Bedoya will do everything of course but
I have more like calluses and so I can
like take it differently than I put up
with it will stick is to progress' or
different okay
a little bit about the length of your
performance and what a typical day looks
right for you it's a resistible day and
then if you have any rules of thumb or
tips and we did you keep your
friendships alive relationship and your
family time kind of protected and also
on time for passion projects and your
stop does it look like I have an
ulterior was I really do
I'm always every day just try and do the
best I can
no two days are the same I'm constantly
trying to create routine so they feel
like that's good and everything that
I've read about successful people is
they start early I hate waking up early
is like personal all of my feelings and
every time I wake up early it's just
like why me
but I spend so much that's what you
cancel see I feel like you start early
vanya I'm not it's not earlier late it's
a for me it's just maximizing when I'm
awake like people always like how you
sleep thinking on the safe three or four
like I'm dying to get to six or seven
because I think it's healthy it's just
that I'm [ __ ] on all 18 hours when
I'm awake right yeah oh they know I wish
I figured out some secret sauce
I don't know I have friends that I am in
close right at certain periods of time
and now we're not and
we're really close web and I kind of
give myself a graded assessment so I
just think that you cannot think of the
pressure of like society immunity maybe
and you're just really true who you are
and know that you're trying to do the
best you can you can kind of just get
enough that or mine here is probably
wrong this is wrong but I I wish it was
better I like waking up early and eating
healthy and exercising and calling my
mom like I just not good at stuff but
I'm good at actually being with the kids
and things and then when they yell at me
enough about the same thing over and
over again I can sometimes say like okay
you're right
telling me nuancing Chinese I mentally
train my question or entrepreneurship
what are your top three factors that
inspires me come out to it and what
wasn't easily prevented three factors
that inspired me to be an entrepreneur
social justice was my big one I felt
like it was completely unfair as only
people who live in concert and tax
bracket deserve to have a better life
and had access clearly not just better
products but more education to make
better choices and so I would say this
one to agree and I wish and lobby for
comical reform and try to work at that
angle and I got
we're and they need a partisan issue is
a human health issue and when you're
like this is just like a civil right
people should just know what's in stuff
and how it's going to affect their
health and the fact that the government
will protect it someone needs to go out
there and prove that people want it and
bold will go whether with their wealth
or and that that's what that would
really chose me every day and that's it
still drives me just thank you so much
for stopping by
[Applause]